[موسيقى]
علاقه المسلمين بالشمس والقمر والنجوم
علاقه استدلاليه فهم يعرفون بدايه شهورهم
عن طريق منازل القمر ويعرفون مواقيت
صلاتهم وقبلتهم عن طريق مواقع الشمس
بالنهار وعن طريق مواقع النجوم بالليل
ومكان وزمان شروق وغروب الشمس يتغير بشكل
يومي طوال ايام السنه يحصل احيانا ان تقطع
الشمس الخط الواصل بين المكان الى مكه
ويشتغل في تحديد القبله وعلماء العالم
الاسلامي هم اول من استخدم هذه الطريقه في
تحديد القبله دعى المحرمون الله يستغفرونه
بمكه
وناديت يا رحمن
كل سئلتي بنفسي ليله ثم انت حسيبها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يوم 15 ديسمبر تغرب الشمس باتجاه القبله
اهل الرياض ويوم 13 ديسمبر تغرب الشمس
باتجاه القبله على المنام ويوم خمسه
فبراير تغرب الشمس باتجاه القبله على
الدوحه ويوم 24 فبراير تغرب الشمس في
اتجاه القبله على ابو ظبي ويوم 12 اكتوبر
تغرب الشمس باتجاه القبله على مسقط وهنالك
يومين في السنه تكون الشمس هي القبله وقت
اذان الظهر على الحرم على مستوى العالم
يوم 27 مايو ويوم 26 يوليو فلا اقسم برب
المشارق والمغارب انا لقادرون على انه
نبدل خيرا منهم وما نحن
المسبوقين
[موسيقى]